llegó el momento de la información
económica aquí en france 24 y por ello
me acompaña en el estudio mi compañera
daniela blandón daniela buenas noches
bienvenida el canal de suez suspendió
oficialmente la navegación y pone en
jaque al comercio mundial
así es valentina buenas noches el
portacontenedores con más de 224 mil
toneladas a bordo va a completar tres
días bloqueando el paso clave entre
europa y asia aunque la principal
consecuencia es ahora para estos dos
continentes en cuestión de días puede
verse reflejado al otro lado del
atlántico si la situación sigue como
ésta las grandes navieras se están
analizando desviar sus rutas por áfrica
pero esto implica al menos una semana
más de recorrido le preguntamos a un
analista qué consecuencias puede tener
esto sobre américa latina'
para latinoamérica inicialmente el
impacto no debe ser tan fuerte pero
recordemos que cuando hay un suceso
particular en una economía por más
lejana que sea puede afectar también a
través de la volatilidad de los mercados
financieros el gran problema será sobre
todo para las economías asiáticas
pensemos sobre todo en japón a donde iba
destinado este buque pero como nosotros
sabemos que la economía es un sistema
interdependiente eso quiere decir que lo
que pasa en asia puede aceptar a europa
a latinoamérica y a muchos otros países
continentes regiones como queramos
imaginar entonces cuando hay un
embotellamiento con un trancón como pasa
con los camiones que no pueden llegar a
su destino puede haber escasez de bienes
esa escasez puede llevar a que los
precios suben hablamos ahora de la
producción mundial de vehículos que el
año pasado que hay un 16 por ciento
valentina en 2019 a vida había sido de
91 7 millones de unidades y en 2020 cayó
a 77,6 millones con lo que retrocedió a
niveles de 2010 sólo cuatro países
subieron su producción el año pasado
están
irán uzbekistán en américa latina'
méxico perdió frente a corea del sur el
sexto puesto en el ranking de los
grandes productores y ahora es el
séptimo y al igual que la gran mayoría
de países del mundo los tres mayores
fabricantes de américa latina' redujeron
su actividad
pasamos ahora a china que arremete
contra las grandes marcas que critican
la situación de los uigures palentina la
televisión estatal china promovió un
boicot contra marcas como la sueca h&m o
la estadounidense en haití la primera
había suspendido la compra de algodón de
la región de xinjiang tras los
señalamientos sobre posible violación de
derechos humanos contra los uigures y
otras minorías musulmanas en esta zona
nike y también había criticado la
situación meses atrás y se le habían
sumado otras como usar a adidas y new
balance
beijing arremetió contra todas estas
marcas extranjeras de ropa y calzado
escuchemos sin sentir primero el algodón
y gillian es uno de los mejores del
mundo y las empresas que no lo utilizan
son las que pierden en segundo lugar la
acusación de trabajo en jersusalén yung
jan es una mentira maliciosa inventada
por puestos individuales antichina con
el propósito de desacreditar la imagen
de chinas y socavar la seguridad y
estabilidad de xinjiang y frenar el
desarrollo de este país
daniela y porque tienen resaca los
fabricantes de whisky de eeuu
o cruda o guayaba o como le queramos
decir están muy afectados porque mira
hace casi dos décadas eeuu mantiene una
disputa comercial por subsidios
aeronáuticos con la unión europea y
ahora con reino unido que derivó en
aranceles de parte y parte recientemente
fueron suspendidas gran parte de esos
gravámenes como muestra de un avance en
el mejoramiento de las relaciones pero
el whisky borbón el tennessee y el
centeno fabricados todos en eeuu
quedaron por fuera de esa exención
valentina el consejo de destilados de
eeuu dijo que esos aranceles que todavía
aplican para las exportaciones de whisky
a europa han tenido un gran impacto en
la industria en efecto la resaca que ya
tenían durante la administración de
donald trump podría haberse más dolorosa
en junio cuando se prevé que ese
sobrecargo ya no va a ser del 25 sino
del 50 por ciento
daniela vamos con los indicadores
económicos wall street el cerró con
ganancias después de que se revelara que
las peticiones semanales de subsidios
por desempleo cayeron a su nivel más
bajo desde que inició la pandemia las
bolsas de europa cerraron mix
con pérdidas en londres y en madrid y en
américa latina la bolsa de sao paulo
subió después de cuatro jornadas en rojo
daniela y la cifra del día 13 como 1
millones de euros valentina en esa cifra
que es recortó para el reconocido
artista
bangkok fue subastado en parís un cuadro
suyo que estuvo oculto en manos privadas
durante nada más y nada menos que un
siglo se trata de escena de calle en
mont marte pintado en 1887 daniela
muchas gracias a ustedes gracias por su
sintonía continúen en france24
[Música]